All right, Hassan, you're up, man. How
you doing?
>> Hey, how you doing? How's everything
going, man?
>> Pretty good, man. You know what would
convert me to Islam?
>> What's that?
>> You know what would convert me to Islam?
>> Uh, what's that?
>> If there was only one Quran that was
word for word identical.
>> Okay. Well, I see you're doing live
debates. So,
>> well, I just had a question. It's my
first time speaking to you. I've seen a
couple of your debate videos with um
Ramsey, Ali Dava.
>> So, it's my first time speaking to you.
I just have a question for you, man.
just generally if you could explain to
me could you explain to me
>> are you going to deal with are you going
to are you here to deal with the topic
or you know like engage or no
>> well I I want to respectfully ask you a
question I've been wanting to ask you
this question for a while if you don't
mind me asking I mean if you just want
to ask me questions and debate we can do
that but I really that's what I want to
do respectful I like
>> I want I want us to get straight to what
will make me a Muslim why why I why any
of us should convert to Islam
>> well no I'm not here to convert you. So
I'm not that's not my intentions coming.
>> You didn't see the title of the stream.
>> Uh yeah, I see it. I convert to Islam.
So I see what what the title is.
>> Yeah. So I would like what some reasons
that would make me believe in Islam.
That's what I want to talk about first
and then you can ask me whatever you
want.
>> Okay.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So, like I said, what will make me
what would make me consider that Islam
has some substance is if there truly was
only one Quran all over the world that
all Muslims memorize word for word,
letter for letter,
>> right?
>> Do you believe that that's the case?
>> Yeah, I believe the Quran is preserved.
It was preserved in Arabic language just
like you know in the previous scriptures
were in different languages. They were
not in English. So, it's been preserved.
So, when you say different uh it's been
changed. Can you explain elaborate?
>> Well, in my studies, I've seen that
there are there are variance there are
textual variances in the Quran like
different Qurans depending on which one
you hold authoritative and reading. Do
you mean by let me uh let me ask you do
you mean like by the translation the
English translations because they are
different
>> the Arabic
>> the Arabic text is exactly the same the
way it it is
>> it's not
>> it is
>> how do what do you mean can you explain
that
>> I'll show example
>> so for example
>> um
>> if we if we go to chapter 10 verse 16
>> okay
>> I'm and I'm going to show you the
English translation of it and then show
you the Arabic Okay.
>> By the way, do you do you speak Arabic?
>> So, I don't speak Arabic. So, I'm not an
Arab. So, that's the thing. So, my
background is Bangladeshi. So,
>> I am able to read
>> Arabic in the Quran cuz we are taught
>> Yeah.
>> to read. But I'm not an Arab. So,
>> just because you're a Muslim doesn't
mean you're an Arab. If you're assuming
that every Muslim is an Arab. No.
>> That's why I asked. I just asked if you
speak Arabic or not. That's all.
>> No, I don't speak Arabic.
>> Awesome. That's all right. So, uh,
>> in chapter 10 verse 16, and so here's
the, uh, here's the verse here. Okay.
>> And I would I do want to say that if you
know if you have specific questions like
you, it's better for you to do bring
someone who's a Muslim and an Arab who
speaks Arabic language who would
probably explain it way better than me.
I'm not a scholar. All right? I'm not a
uh, someone who's
>> I understand. I just want to give you
just like not every Christian is a
scholar. I just want to give you some
information about
>> Okay. Okay. All right. Sure.
>> All right.
>> So, this is one of the differences that
uh I found and and it was Arabic
speakers that showed me this actually.
So, so it says here it says say so this
is chapter 10 16 it says
>> say if Allah had willed I would not have
recited it to you nor would he have made
it known to you for I had remained among
you a lifetime before then will you not
reason.
>> Okay. So pretty clear in what it says.
You know, if Allah had willed and he
didn't want Muhammad to recite the
Quran, Allah would not have made the
Quran known to them either. Right? So
that's what he says.
>> Okay?
>> Right? So now this is the Huff's
rendering of the Quran. This is comes
from the Huffs and I have it over here
on the right side, the same verse. Uh
this comes from the Huff's reading of
the Quran and I have it in Arabic over
here. Right? And uh the phrase is I
don't know if you can see. Hold on. Let
me try to expand. But if I expand it
does that. It's so annoying. Hold on.
Let me do this. Okay. Yeah, we we'll
keep it like this. All right. So, you
see where my mouse is?
>> Yeah, I see that.
>> Okay. So, where it says
>> I can read Arabic, but I'm not an Arab,
but I'm able to read the Quran because
we every Muslim is taught.
>> So, you guys recite. I know. says, you
know, even if you're not an Arab or you
don't understand Arabic, every Muslim is
taught to read the Quran and they
memorize it in this in the same text.
>> Yeah, but it's okay.
I understand that you guys believe this,
brother. Trust me, I understand that you
guys believe that you memorize in the
same text. I'm about to show you that
you guys don't in the same text.
>> Okay, sure.
>> So, this is the uh the phrase right here
where it says, "Nor would he have made
it known to you." this phrase, that's
the phrase that we're going to be
talking about.
>> Okay.
>> And that's this right here. This these
words right here in the Arabic.
>> So that says,
"Okay, go ahead."
>> Yep. So this is nor would he have made
it known to you. Right.
>> Now when we go scroll down to another
reading of the Quran, uh this is Ali's
reading from
>> Okay.
>> Here we have it right here. It's
different and it color codes the
difference.
It's the It's the same. So, okay, hold
on. Let me zoom in, man.
>> Yeah. Let me try.
>> I can read this. Oh, it says, "Can you
go back to the previous one, please?"
It's the same thing. I don't know what
you
>> Do you see the text?
>> Is there a lamb?
>> Go back to the other one, please. Okay.
It's the same. I'm not sure what you're
trying to say, man. It's not it's not
the same
>> because I can read Arabic perfectly. I
can read but
>> they they even color code the
difference. Even the diritical marks are
different. They color code the
difference.
>> You see the difference between this
purple here.
>> Okay. I see. Yeah. Voila. That's voila.
>> Do you see the difference here,
>> bro? It's it's it's lot.
>> It's completely different.
>> No, it's the same exact thing. It's not
the same exact thing because I even know
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Do you see
that alf right there? The olive. Okay. I
don't know if you know the if you know
the alphab.
>> Yeah, this is an olive. Uhhuh.
>> Yeah. So that's a silent.
>> That's wa. So look at look the the word.
So you see Wah. So you know the W,
right? You know the alphabet Arabic
alphabet. Arab. Do you know that?
>> Not. No.
>> So that's W.
Then the olive goes with the dal. So
that's alum.
>> Yeah.
Go back to the same thing. Go back to
Yeah, there's a law right there next to
>> It's still there.
>> It's not going. It's there.
>> So, this one says, "Nor would he have
made it known to you." Right.
>> Okay. But the Arabic text is the same.
That's what I'm telling you.
>> No, this one says, this one says he
would have made it known. It doesn't say
nor would he have made it. It says he
would have made it known.
>> Are we looking at the English or Arabic?
Can we just Can we
>> We're looking at the Arabic.
>> Let's clarify something. Are we looking
at the English or Arabic? We're looking
at the Arabic.
>> Okay. So the Arabic over there.
So if if you go to the other one, it's
the same exact Arabic text. It's the
same.
>> I'm not sure if you mean by the English
translation.
>> Let me let me let me even show you that
this the scholars recognize the variant
reading. Let me show you cuz this this
I'm not making this up.
>> Are we going by English or are we going
by the Arabic? Cuz it's the same exact
thing, man.
>> Okay. So this is Tier Jalain. says,
"Say, if God had willed, I would not
have recited it to you, nor would he
have made it known to you."
>> Okay?
>> Right? Nor would he have made it made
you aware. The law of
adraum is for negation. Do you agree
with that in the in the text? The law of
adraum.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> And is a supplement to what preceded a
variant reading has the lum.
>> So every hold on you cuz earlier you
said that the Arabic text is different.
Are we going you said not the Arabic
earlier what you said was
>> the Arabic text is different
>> text is different. This is why
>> Arabic text is the same. It's the same.
>> This is why the this is why the website
even color I can even see the different
diiocritical marks here. Bro, do you do
you see the different diietritical marks
on the you see the different
diietritical marks on the olive?
>> What about it?
>> It's different, is it not?
>> Can you go back to the other text,
>> brother? Do you see?
>> I'm reading cuz I I I can read the
Quran. I can read the Arabic. Fine.
>> Hold on. Let me just let me just
So what are Cuz you're explaining the
English text. You said the Arabic.
>> No, I'm explaining the Arabic. Let me
see if you can be honest with this, bro.
>> I'm straight up with you, man.
>> Okay. If you're being straight up,
>> does this have the same diritical marks
as this?
>> Well, that's so the text is black color.
The other one's purple. What What are
you getting at?
>> Do you know what the diritical marks
are?
>> Brother, do you know what do you know
what diritical marks are in the Arabic?
Okay. So, the diritical marks, do you
see do you see the markings like above
the letters? You see these marks?
>> Those are the diritical marks. Those
>> Okay.
>> will determine the grammar or
>> Okay. Yes. Okay.
>> All right.
>> So, because the diritical marks are
different between this and the black
>> that that that where you have the arrow
right there that's so when you reciting
it, let me explain. So, when you
reciting it,
>> you're about to explain what what you
needed me to tell you.
>> Okay. You don't want me to explain it to
you? You can go ahead and explain it.
You know, you know, you know,
>> you you didn't know what the diritical
marks were before I before I
>> No, I know they are, but the the way So,
I think you're a little confused, man.
So, when you're reciting it in Arabic,
right? So, this is like ancient Arabic
text. So, when you're reciting it, these
texts help you pronounce. So, if you
look at the So, right there,
>> do you do you know that
what the word
>> my man just listen to me, right? Do you
understand because you're cuz I I don't
have much time.
>> No. I guess you're busy.
>> Do you understand that the diiacritical
marks change the word?
>> Okay. So, look, I'm going to explain
that to you right now. So, that's voila.
Right now, if you go back to the other
one,
>> can you go the Can you scroll to the
other one, please?
>> Take care, bro.
>> So, that's still
>> wasting my time again. I can't get any I
can't get any any real people any any
real people here to to talk to. I can't
waste my time. This is insane. This is
insane. Any any real people here, man?
Please, I beg of you. I I I'm leaving at
in in 10 minutes. I need a real somebody
real. Can somebody real engage? Somebody
real.